en una rara conmemoración pública de los
soldados muertos en la guerra cientos de
personas se reunieron en Samara en el
occidente de Rusia muchos de los
soldados que fueron alcanzados por
misiles ucranianos el día de año nuevo
eran de la ciudad
no podemos quebrarnos Y el dolor nos une
se los aseguro
aplastaremos juntos al enemigo
Rusia aseguró que el número de soldados
que perdieron la vida más kipka era
mayor a los 63 que habían reportado el
martes
en la inspección de los escombros de las
construcciones de hormigón armado el
número de nuestros camaradas muertos
llegó a 89
actualmente una comisión Investiga las
circunstancias del ataque pero ya está
claro que la causa principal fue el
encendido y uso masivo por parte del
personal de teléfonos móviles dentro del
alcance de las armas enemigas en contra
de la prohibición
el ataque causó grandes descontento en
la opinión pública rusa criticando
Ucrania y a sus aliados occidentales
también blogueros corresponsales de
guerra incluso legisladores han
expresado su enfado con el mando militar
por la debacle de mcca andrey
vicepresidente del parlamento manifestó
su descontento por Telegram Es peligroso
y Criminal considerar al enemigo como un
tonto que no ve nada durante el décimo
mes de la guerra poner en cualquier
lugar de los edificios en lugar de
ponerlas en refugios es una ayuda
directa al enemigo a pesar del aumento
del número de fallecidos por parte de
Rusia este no se acerca al reportado por
Ucrania las autoridades del país
aseguraron que fueron